RAVI LACHHMAN: Hi, everybody.
My name is Ravi Lachhman.
I'm an evangelist at Harness
and very excited to be
talking at Google Cloud Next.
I had a lot of
outages in my day,
so hopefully we can
learn a little bit
how not to get burned.
But also with me is my
esteemed colleague, Brett.
Brett?
BRETT ZANE-ULMAN: Hi,
I'm Brett Zane-Ulman.
I'm an engineering
manager here at Harness.
And I'm excited
to be here today.
Go ahead, Ravi.
RAVI LACHHMAN: Perfect.
So what we're going to
be talking about today--
so at Harness,
we've actually went
through a pretty big
migration on GCP.
But a little bit
of level setting,
what on earth is Harness?
And we'd like to decide
our time before GCP,
our time on the way to
GCP, and our time on GCP.
It's very nicely segmented here.
So in the beginning, let's talk
a little bit about Harness.
A divine light came
down and shined
upon the continuous delivery
world, and Harness was born.
So again, a bright light shined.
So what are we actually
talking about here?
We're talking about Harness.
At Harness, we're a continuous
delivery as a service.
So what does that mean?
A continuous
delivery as a service
is something that
helps orchestrate
a couple of parts for you.
So getting your software or
your platforms into production
really requires orchestration
between approvals,
all the confidence
building steps
that you have, such as
testing, and also just a way
to do release, right?
So are you leveraging a safe
type of release like a canary?
So you see the canary
doing a dab there.
Are you doing a blue-green?
Now if these terms are
new to you, don't worry.
We'll be here after the
presentation to kind of answer
some questions.
But Harness really packages all
that up for you as a service.
Also, since we have a lot of
customers that depend on us,
we always have to be up.
And so what the Harness
platform does is exactly that.
We're supporting over 100
enterprises, thousands
of community users, and
also, hundreds of thousands
of deployments regularly.
Ironically, we actually
help empower people coming
and talking on stages
in different technology
conferences because
if you're looking
at where their applications
go, most likely,
they could be using
Harness in the background
to help deploy that.
And so what do we
deal with at Harness?
We actually have some unique
challenges at Harness,
is that we have a SaaS
version of our product.
So people expect
uptime all the time.
But also, we're supporting two
other type of cloud deployment
models.
I like to call it
kind of SaaS, right?
So certain customers
might not like being
completely in the public cloud.
And so there's
limited connection.
They're running parts
of the Harness platform
on their hardware.
And also, we have a
completely Air Gap version--
I call it No SaaS'in Around--
of the products so customers
can be completely disconnected,
again, in trying to leverage
the Harness platform.
And so what are some of the
challenges of the platform,
right?
Because again, we
have to maintain
three different versions
of our platform.
So the first thing
before our time with GCP
was scaling of the platform
is basically non-existent.
We had a very
rigid architecture.
And Brett will walk through
that in a couple of minutes.
Also, this was our first
foray into Kubernetes.
Actually, none of our
workload for ourselves
were hosted or deployed
on the Kubernetes.
Now a lot of our customers
are using Kubernetes.
But it was actually our
first foray into Kubernetes.
We went to GCP.
And also, we had no
separation of duty, right?
So what that means
is that we didn't
have lower
environments deploying
to other different
lower environments.
Basically, our prod
environments that we
were building the platform
on deployed straight to prod.
So we had the lack of
separation of duties.
And also, we had
multiple versions
of the platform, which was
becoming difficult to maintain.
And also, we were
completely on SaaS.
So that means that any
sort of downtime for us
would be very detrimental
to the customers.
And so, I'm about to
hand it over to Brett.
Let's talk about our time,
Brett, before the mighty GCP.
Brett?
BRETT ZANE-ULMAN:
Sure, Ravi, thanks.
So as Ravi mentioned, our
production environment
prior to moving to
GCP was pretty rigid.
This is basically
what it looked like.
It's very simple.
We had just a couple
of EC2 instances that
were hosting our UI, which
is just some static content
and then three other VMs running
our orchestration servers
and connecting to our database.
Each one was behind
a load balancer.
And that was pretty much it.
What we had to do is
update every time we
want to deploy a new version.
And Harness is a
deployment tool.
So of course, we're using
Harness to deploy Harness.
But at this time, we didn't have
any other environments set up
for deploying to production.
So production deployed itself.
And how did this work?
So our servers, which
are called managers,
orchestrate workflow
executions during a deployment.
But the actual calls to
deploy and update a service
are done by a worker, or
delegate, in the customer
environment.
So in this case, being
our own customer,
our delegate is in the
same VPC as the servers.
And while the
workflow runs, it goes
through one server at a
time, updating the binary
and restarting the service.
This is all well and good,
except that during the course
of the deployment, the
orchestration engine
itself gets updated
to a new version.
And since it relies on
communicating back and forth
with the delegate, it's very
sensitive to data model changes
that may have been introduced
by the new version.
Of course, if this
goes wrong and hangs,
then you get stuck
with production
in an intermediate state.
RAVI LACHHMAN: And now it's
time to introduce Kubernetes.
So given all the
challenges that we had,
looking to really leverage
Kubernetes to help
overcome that, a
lot of our customers
are moving towards Kubernetes.
And also our platform actually
deploys to Kubernetes.
So the next rational
step for us was actually
to be going towards Kubernetes.
Brett, let's talk
about some reasons
why we were looking to leverage
our very own Kubernetes.
BRETT ZANE-ULMAN: Sure, Ravi.
So, as Ravi mentioned, over
the first year that we even
had a production environment,
we saw the rise of Kubernetes
in popularity.
It was becoming more and more
popular with our customers.
And so we wanted to
leverage that for ourselves.
Our primary goal was to
dockerize our microservices
and start using Kubernetes.
And when we looked
around at the time,
GKE was really the best and one
of the only hosted Kubernetes
services.
We already had Kubernetes
support in Harness on GKE,
so why not leverage that
and use it for ourselves?
So we built out
the infrastructure
and defined all of our
Kubernetes configuration
in Harness to deploy all
of our microservices,
exposing an NGINX Ingress
Controller via a load balancer
and then routing to
our various services.
So once this had been
working in QA for some time,
we were ready to make
the switch in production.
So making the migration
is what we're here for.
So let's talk about that.
RAVI LACHHMAN: Yeah, this
is what the people came for.
We have two pieces of
infrastructure now.
How do we make the solution?
[INAUDIBLE] And it's
so kind of gearing up
towards the switch, kind of the
ethos that we have at Harness,
that we help enable
people doing production
changes in normal hours, right?
If you kind of take a look
back at years gone by,
usually, you're deploying
during your green window
or a black window.
Pick your color, right?
It's 2:00 or 3:00
in the morning.
And everyone's tired, right?
And so since we
help enable people
make this type of deployment
or really critical deployments
in normal business
hours for the geography,
we decided to drink
our own champagne
or eat our own dog
food, that, hey,
let's do a dinner time
switch, because we
had two sets of team.
So around dinnertime
in San Francisco
is actually breakfast
time in India.
So for all the resources
that we had to line up,
it made the best sense for us
to do it around dinner time.
And so Brett, let's talk a
little bit about the switch
that we had to do.
BRETT ZANE-ULMAN: Sure.
So we were migrating not
only our own infrastructure,
but also our database, which
is a hosted Atlas Mongo DB
cluster.
While the old production
instances on the left
were still live, we deployed and
brought up the new Kubernetes
stack, pointed at the
database that was still
in AWS at the time, just to
make sure it was running fine,
well connected to
the production DB,
but without any traffic
reaching it yet.
So once that works, we
scaled it back down.
Then, for the database, we
live migrated the data over
to another Atlas cluster,
this time hosted in GCP.
The data there was keeping
pace with the live production
database with a
few seconds of lag.
Then, to make the switch, we
took a few minutes of downtime,
turned down the old
production instances,
so that they stop
writing to the database,
then wait a few moments for
the database live migration
to catch up completely.
Then we finalized
the data migration.
So then we reconfigured the
new Kubernetes manager to point
to the new database in GCP
and redeployed with Harness.
So once that was up and
verified on our end,
the only thing left was
to switch the DNS entry
to the IP of the
new load balancer.
RAVI LACHHMAN: Awesome.
And not wanting to
do the big reveal,
but it's in the title
of our presentation.
How long do you
think it actually
took us to make the kind
of [INAUDIBLE] switch?
And the big reveal--
this is actually
live Slack from when
we made the switch.
It was a total of 76 minutes.
And it was very impressive
that this change only took
76 minutes for us to execute.
But maybe we could
talk a little bit
about what the final ecosystem
looked like for us, given
the benefits and some
of the lacking stuff
we had in our old
architecture, Brett.
BRETT ZANE-ULMAN: Sure.
So I mentioned previously
some of the problems
with the self deployment
model and the data
model changes that
can cause problems
when we upgrade ourselves.
So what we've done
now, we've added
a number of new microservices.
And we've introduced a new
internal Harness environment
that deploys production,
so we're not self
deploying anymore.
And we've also introduced
versioning to address the data
model changes that I mentioned.
So the payload is synchronized
between the servers
and the workers at all
times via the versioning.
So now we're able to
quickly scale using GKE
and meet new demand or deal
with production issues.
This is an example of
what our pipelines look
like while they're running.
And with the products using
these types of pipelines,
we're able to wrangle all
the configuration that you
need to stand up your services.
And that definitely
helped us when
we were changing both the cloud
provider and the deployment
model at the same time.
RAVI LACHHMAN: Yeah, absolutely.
And I think just kind of adding
to some of Brett's points
there, we are a continuous
delivery company.
And it really shows
the importance
for making such a big
infrastructure change that
actually leverage a pipeline.
As we were going through
the development and also
the testing of this,
it's kind of interesting,
as the kind of the shift of
infrastructure to the cloud
allows for a lot more iteration,
and so running the pipelines,
kind of testing out what would
happen in success scenarios,
what would happen in failure
scenarios, was quite important.
So it wasn't all,
this is the first time
we're doing something.
There was a lot of trial
and error to get this right.
But with all of that, with all
the trials and tribulations,
right, we made a
fairly big change.
And it has really
paid off for us,
partnering with Google Cloud,
that we're able to, A, we're
increasing the number of
customers that we have,
the infrastructure
scaling appropriately,
and just really allowing us to
grow and scale our business.
And so don't forget
after all this is done
and to celebrate success,
and really looking
at a very simple equation
for what is success, right?
So there was certainly a
lot of prep work, right,
so gathering and
planning, taking inventory
of what you have, making sure
that these particular pieces,
especially as we started to
move towards more dockerization,
right?
It's a very, very [INAUDIBLE]
approach that we took.
Also, for execution,
make sure you
have the right staff in place.
If it's 2:00 or
3:00 in the morning,
it doesn't do anybody
a favor, right, if it's
a time that everyone's awake.
You're certainly more alert.
And also, the journey
is never over, right?
A common thing that we like to
ask our prospects and customers
is, hey, when is
your deployment over?
It's kind of an
intrinsic question.
Because, again, you
always want to make sure
that you're always refining
and continually approving
what you do have.
That kind of lasting impact that
we have for Google Cloud, even
our leveraging
technologies like GKE,
when we have new engineers even
from field sales to customer
support to even engineering
where Brett's at, teaching them
on Kubernetes and GKE makes
it easier for us, right?
So they have an easy way
to kind of see and play
with Kubernetes.
And thanks once again for
catching our presentation.
Brett and I really appreciated
you coming to catch our talk.
And hopefully, we can
catch up with everybody
in person one of these days.
Cheers.